the way i'm going to segue into this is
to
try and call back the last two lessons
we've looked at the last two lessons
okay
so just under a review right
what did we look at yesterday do you
remember what we looked at yesterday
symmetry good we looked at all different
kinds
of symmetry and we noticed how many
there were okay good that was yesterday
what about the day before what do we
look at
well after that after that we looked at
oh we looked at maps
we looked at maps right well done we
looked at specifically
we looked at the four color theorem
right uh but we're just kind of mucking
around with maps and cartography and all
that
and here's what's interesting okay um
these two topics
what do they have to do with each other
you're like well not much
right well i'd like to try and convince
you
otherwise i'm going to show you some
maps actually i'm going to show you some
maps
i'll ask you a couple of questions as we
go through this okay so here's my um
actually hold on a second i want to make
sure i get the right map
okay hold up i'm gonna sorry i'm gonna
turn this off for a second so that you
um
we're going to turn into something else
there we go as long as you look at
something else what is it
ah beautiful okay yes it's fine
okay excellent
all right i've got it
bigger okay now what are we looking at i
know it's super blurry it's okay i'm
still going to be able to make the point
go away menu go away
there we go uh i know it's super blurry
that's partly because we're very zoomed
into something
that we are going to zoom out on but
what you're looking at is a river
right you're looking at a river and you
can kind of recognize oh now that you
know that it's river
right it's got this kind of you know
it's it's thicker here and it sort of
goes in and then it narrows off and it
evaporates or wherever it does
and it's got all these little branches
that come off it okay now this is a very
typical
winding sort of river okay it could be
any river
just in case you're curious it's a river
in egypt which will become significant
in a second
okay now here's what i'm going to do
it's not the night
um i'm going to zoom out a little bit i
want to see a little more of this map
okay
and i want to see what you notice about
this
all right now there we go um the part
you saw before is what's in that red
rectangle okay
so you were looking at this part and now
you can see
more of this system now what's
interesting
what kinds of things do you notice
yeah it looks it does look like if you
turn it um sideways
it does kind of look like the roots of
the tree um of a tree this kind of
structure
is not unique to rivers it's not just
rivers it's not just trees
a lot more other things like this
anything else you notice
say again no okay so you're thinking of
more things that similar to
good yeah new york that's fine it's fine
good um we did talk about neuroscience
history so i don't believe it
looks kind of similar there is some
similarity
isn't there now i wonder if you're
starting to see why i said there's a
connection between these two
similarity is a kind of symmetry which
one is it
we gave it a name
it's one it's one of the kinds of
geometric symmetry which one
it's not it's not um it's not
translational symmetry
i can't take this you just move around
what is it yeah
i can see number one i can see
rotational right because you know if i
say sort of
rotate this around but there's another
thing as well
oh yeah i'm thinking of well
oh do you wanna say something yeah i can
see some scale symmetry
can't you like for example okay look at
this original map you can see it just
sort of
uh branches off like that the technical
word by the way
is it um it bifurcates
this is going to be an important word
later on which one i mentioned here it
splits into
two right uh but not only does this
splinter two but this this larger system
also splits into two okay so we're
getting some kind of scale symmetry here
right as well as rotation
let's zoom out again
okay now the map you just saw right
that was in the red rectangle so now
we've gone out further
now this is very interesting though the
river is widening
but as it goes that kind of scale
symmetry that you were talking about
before
it's starting to go kind of crazy isn't
it it's not exactly
perfectly similar but you're seeing the
same kind of
branching behavior all over the place
it bifurcates again and again hundreds
of times
okay shall we go a little further
you're like whoa hello tell me about the
oh yeah like veins you might even look
at depending on
if you're the kind of person who your
veins stick out of your hands and that
kind of thing i'm one of those okay
this looks familiar doesn't it and as we
go further and further
out we're seeing the same kind of
structure let me go one more time
there we go whoops that i'm gonna get
rid of the um
red rectangle now because i don't think
now this is a huge huge
river system right it's massive but
what's astonishing apart from its
stability
is is this scale symmetry that you can
see
at all these different places okay now
this is not the only place you can find
it
um you can also see it let's go to
there we go um here we go here's another
kind of river system
and you can you're seeing the same kind
of thing right and this one is kind of
it's it's a bit easier to be bamboozled
by all the beautiful colors okay
but you've got the same kind of thing
happening right and you can see this is
bordering the ocean
okay now this pattern this shape is so
important
we give it its own name it's a big
big subset of certainly does anyone know
what this kind of shape
is called anyway
if you if you oh there we go read your
course outline you might recognize
and you can make this heading this kind
of shape
this is called a fractal
so gonna make this heading right now
we're gonna look at and construct
a whole bunch of these but before we do
that let's try and put down like what
are these things like we can sort of get
a sense of it
but how would you define it okay i'll
give you as simple
a definition as i can a fractal is
okay um it's a figure
or a shape or a space
i'll just say shape right
that exhibits
and i'm going to give you a new
important phrase it's very closely
related to scale symmetry
right that exhibits self
similarity
at every level
of magnification let me say that all
again
and then we'll unpack it a fractal is a
shape
or figure or space or later on we're
going to look at functions
that exhibits self-similarity this is
the key phrase
at every level of magnification right
and there's levels of magnification
well what we were looking at before
right you can zoom in and in
and you'll get the same shape the same
pattern
if you like you can call it like sort of
a repeating pattern if you want
at every level okay now i've actually
already shown you some of these right
um do you remember we had a look at the
nautilus shell because we were thinking
about the golden spiral right
and you had this shape going out like
this okay but as you zoom in you've got
these like
subsections of the shell
does anyone know what are these
subsections do they don't know what they
represent
baby nautilus right tiny tiny little
thing okay
still got a shell it's like that big
okay but then eventually
it eats it grows it's too big for this
little space
right so it grows a new part of the
shell
that is similar because its body is
still the same shape it's just getting
bigger
right this is similar to the original
right and then
it outgrows that one and it outgrows
that one and it keeps on going right so
these are all
like i suppose it's kind of growing
pains
okay now we're going to build a bunch of
these
right these kinds of things you're like
what how am i supposed to build this
well
we'll start simply